In
the late 1960s, NASA’s Apollo missions were
in full swing, with both Apollos 8 and 10
having successfully launched, orbited the
Moon and returned with their astronauts safely
to the Earth.
By the summer of 1969, the space program was
ready to try something new – land a craft
with men on the Moon, and then re-launch and
bring them safely home.
Given the numerous engineering and other difficulties
inherent in the project, Apollo 11’s mission
was considered extraordinarily high-risk.
Accordingly, the men who were assigned to
the mission, Neil Armstrong, Michael Collins
and Edwin “Buzz” Aldrin, had to face the
strong possibility that they would not return
from the mission (particularly Aldrin and
Armstrong).
This was not only a major problem for the
astronauts themselves, but also a more down
to Earth problem for their immediate family.
You see, very unfortunately back then a woman’s
ability to support herself and potential children
financially often came down to “find a husband.”
With said husbands potentially dead on the
Moon, they needed a backup plan for support.
The solution here, of course, would simply
be a good life insurance policy…
But others were equally aware of the questionable
probability of success of this particular
mission.
In fact, an insurance policy on the life of
any of the astronauts was reported to cost
at minimum several times the astronauts’
annual salaries (which were about $15,000-$20,000,
or about $105,000-$140,000 today).
Needless to say, this wasn’t a viable option.
Still needing to ensure their families’
futures, and knowing the value of memorabilia
associated with the missions, the Apollo 11
astronauts decided to leave behind a series
of keepsake autographs, called insurance covers
or postal covers.
In the world of stamp and postal memorabilia
collecting, cover is the term used to describe
the exterior of a package or envelope.
For the Apollo 11 covers, the astronauts obtained
illustrated covers from two makers, the Manned
Spacecraft Center Stamp Club (MSCSC Covers)
and Al Bishop (Bishop Covers).
Displaying various illustrations of what the
Moon landing should look like, images of the
mission’s emblem and even likenesses of
the men and/or the Moon, the covers were rather
decorative and would be highly prized, particularly
if the astronauts failed to return.
During the month prior to the launch, Armstrong,
Collins and Aldrin had been quarantined in
an effort to reduce the risk of one or all
of them catching an illness that might prevent
them from participating in the mission.
With little else to do in their downtime,
they signed hundreds of covers, and then left
them with a trusted individual.
On the day of the launch and/or day of the
lunar landing, the individual with the covers
took them to the post office to have the stamps
cancelled, thus adding to the covers’ value.
Of course, the men of Apollo 11 returned safely,
and this unique form of life insurance turned
out to have been unnecessary.
But knowing a good idea when they saw one,
subsequent Apollo astronauts followed in Armstrong,
Collins, and Aldrin’s footsteps.
As such, covers were signed by the men who
flew Apollos 12, 13, 14, 15 and 16- all missions
in which men were to land on the Moon.
Thankfully, all returned safe and sound.
You might at this point be wondering about
Apollo 17.
Officially, no covers were prepared by the
astronauts of the final Apollo mission.
Why?
Mainly because of the infamous Apollo 15 stamp
scandal in which the astronauts took this
idea a bit further and smuggled aboard 398
unauthorized covers (to go along with the
243 authorized covers NASA had sent up in
partnership with the U.S. Postal Service)
which they took to the Moon and back.
100 of the 398 unauthorized covers were sold
to stamp dealer Hermann Sieger for a total
of $21,000 ($7,000 for each astronaut or about
$40,000 each today).
These were supposed to be held and not sold
until after the Apollo program was over and
were to serve as college funds for the astronauts’
kids.
However, Sieger deciding to start selling
them before the Apollo program had ended.
The news media caught wind of it and the astronauts
in question got in some major hot water from
Congress over the ordeal, not long before
the Apollo 17 mission was to launch.
Needless to say, the astronauts of Apollo
17 were keen on keeping their signing of these
“life insurance” covers secret and when
they survived the mission, there was no reason
to reveal they did it, though later some of
the covers were sold or given away.